c'est un des sites les plus contaminés
au québec on parle de l'ex technoparc de
montréal ça se trouve le long de
l'autoroute bonaventure et qui polluent
chaque jour le fleuve saint laurent et
jean sébastien vous avez obtenu les
résultats d'une étude qui nous apprend
comment les autorités voudraient tenter
de régler ce problème qui dure depuis
des années
voilà comment confiner ces eaux
souterraines soulier et comme ensuite
les capter les pompes et il y en aurait
écouté plusieurs centaines de mètres
cubes qui se retrouveraient chaque jour
en dehors du terrain particulièrement
dans le fleuve
d'abord pour vous situer là vous allez
le voir sur une carte et sur les images
aériennes je me trouve actuellement près
des studios mel et christian le long de
l'autoroute bonaventure
cet énorme sites contaminés se situe
grosso modo entre le pont champlain à
l'ouest et le pont victoria alès entre
l'ancienne gare de triage du cn ona et
le fleuve saint laurent au chu il faut
savoir qu'à partir de 1860
ici la ville s'en est servi comme
dépotoir un immense dépotoir où on
enterrait d'émettre des maîtres de
déchets domestiques industriels des
produits souvent hautement toxique
toxiques est soluble comme des bpc y
aurait jusqu'à 8000 litres de diesel
également alors ça fait longtemps qu'on
veut faire quelque chose il ya une étude
de faisabilité qu'on a fait l'an dernier
et les responsables de la ville du
ministère de l'environnement et de la
société des ponts ont décidé de l'option
qui serait la plus envisageable c'est à
dire la construction d'un mur ancré dans
le rock sur le territoire de montréal
juste derrière moi avant le fleuve pour
donc empêcher l'autre se rendent dans le
flou mais ensuite la pompe est une
solution à peu près 60 2 millions de
dollars pour les 15 premières années
mais on sait pas encore qui va payer
on sait pas encore quand ce sera les
écologistes en omar veulent que ça bouge
je laisse écouter la directrice générale
du cre et montréal il va falloir le
faire rapidement puis rappelé que
l'administration de monsieur tremblay en
2008 avait déjà dit que c'était un
dossier important qu'il faudrait qu'ils
soient réglés en 2012
en étant 2014 il n'est pas réglée alors
on espère que l'administration de
monsieur coderre va prendre sans me puis
on a dans une perspective 2017 on veut
fêter montréal le 375e
je pense que ça serait un beau cadeau
pour montréal de dire qu' on est en
règle cette question là qu'on arrête de
polluer de façon phénoménale le fleuve
saint laurent
bonjour sébastien en attendant qu'une
décision soit prise sur le site en tant
que telle qu'est ce que l'on fait
concrètement pour éviter le pire
depuis 1991 hessel devait à l'origine
est une solution temporaire vous allez
voir sur les images et on installe des
sortes de boudin absorbant près du
terrain dans le fleuve aux abords du
terrain donc pour absorber une partie
des hydrocarbures déversés on a aussi
planté des saules des saules qui se
nourrissent des contaminants diminue
donc là zot mais vous comprendrez que ce
sont des solutions temporaires des
solutions imparfaite et on espère donc
au cours des prochaines années ça va
bouger plus concrètement jean-sébastien
merci beaucoup au revoir au revoir